[Music]
foreign
along with many other people on social
media I recently became aware of a live
stream dating podcast on the whatever
YouTube channel whatever is the name of
the channel and this um appeared on my
radar thanks to a truly delightful clip
where a young lady becomes enraged and
storms out of the room
after a man on the panel says that he
doesn't want to sleep with other men
this is the sort of statement expressing
a desire to not engage in homosexual
activity that counts as provocative
outrageous in our culture today I
thought the man handles the exchange
quite well let's take a look
Chase would you rather smash the hottest
trans woman in the world or the oldest
woman in the world honestly bro
the oldest woman in the world because
then I wouldn't be gay
what
you really just want me to just um
are you like Chase how dare you be
transphobic Yes actually what the
do you mean yes because if I had sex
with a trans woman I'd be having sex
with a biological man and I don't want
to do that the question is why
why don't you make it shut the up
because I have an opinion that differs
from yours
that's right I mean that's really cool
she's not it would technically be
homosexual
a trans woman is a biological man sue me
dude that's mean
what's up it's real it's true okay if
you guys you guys want to respect that
right
any sexuality
I'm not allowed to say that I'm not
allowed to say that
woman
[Music]
a man of God doesn't judge a Christian
yeah yeah you know you know what God
said it said
you made the manual I just told you I'm
not gay I'll pass on that thanks though
that's too far she says not wanting to
have sexual relations with a man is is
too far his Center his heterosexuality
is simply a bridge too far for this
young lady who along with her friend has
no choice but to flee the room and
disgust we must admit though that she
made a compelling argument to quote her
she says I don't even care if you're
doing this for like whatever but like
shut the f up actually
that's the kind of quote that would make
Mark Twain proud such incredible wit and
insight and and uh and all of it
communicated with such efficiency
now we can't blame her really for for
not being able to uh intelligently
articulate her objection to this man's
point of view on the subject it is an
unintelligible objection rooted in her
unthinking allegiance to gender ideology
which is also unintelligible
but the problem is that every clip that
circulates from this show which seems to
feature a different group of young women
and sometimes young men each episode
talking about their experiences in the
dating world uh every clip is is just as
mind-numbing and displays an equally
tenuous grasp on the English language so
here's one that attracted widespread
attention yesterday
um watch
I think like the biggest thing that like
annoys me in like the whole dating world
is like talking stages like that's so
annoying like the whole like
and just like the inconsistency in them
like I literally like hate that like so
much but I think that's like my biggest
thing is just like what specifically
just like the fact of just like you like
I don't know how to word this
like in like talking stages and it's
just like you're like labeled that and
it's like people like are considered
like you can't like you're just like
confused and like most of the time like
the girl get but gets like attached or
something and they like see it like it's
gonna lead to a relationship and it's
always not and it's just like
that's like my biggest thing is like I
just hate the whole like how like
talking stages are so like normalized
like traditional dating does not exist
in this generation
now I'm informed by others who have
endured the clip and who had more time
on their hands that she used the word
like 27 times in the span of about 48
seconds haven't checked their math but
it sounds right
I suppose it's no wonder that the girl
doesn't like the talking stage given
that she seems to have so much trouble
talking
the unfortunate thing is that what she's
trying to express is actually important
it's uh it's an important Insight that
she is trying to trying to get across
it's just that it gets crushed under the
weight of a million likes
she's making the point or sort of
verbally gesturing towards the point
that the total banishment of labels and
traditions and Concepts like chivalry
from the dating scene
has left everyone feeling paralyzed and
Confused it means that most single
people end up in a kind of stasis a
limbo not knowing whether they're in a
relationship or what to do if they are
in one or what to call it
and nobody knows what to call anything
the fear of commitment that permeates
our culture the aggressive sort of
casualness of everything the insistence
on approaching all matters especially
matters relating to love and
relationships in a way that
diametrically opposes how our
grandparents approached it all of these
factors have made the dating scene not
simply difficult but effectively
non-existent people don't date they just
sort of float along on the cultural
current hoping that they bump into
another piece of debris before moving on
to the next there's no sense of purpose
or meaning certainly there's no clear
Direction
I think that's what she was trying to
say but instead she said like that like
it's all like so like you know like so
weird like whatever like
she doesn't fully understand her own
feelings on the subject nor does she
have the ability to communicate those
feelings uh she knows about 10 words
total and can only arrange and rearrange
them until she ends up with a sequence
that gets the closest to whatever
half-form thought she wants to express
now
it's not my intention to pick on this
poor girl she's uh she's she's not a
unique or extreme case
that's exactly why it's worth talking
about she is rather a typical product of
her generation
as nearly every older person has noted
Americans seem to be less articulate
with each passing generation and we're
now at a point where some people in gen
Z aren't even proficient in the one and
only language they know they're not
bilingual they're not even monolingual
they are non-lingual effectively
this is not the same as the familiar old
person complaint about youth slang right
that's not what this is the issue is not
slang
it isn't uh what words they've added to
the English language but rather what
words they've removed from it which is
most of them we are rapidly running out
of words as several Generations in a row
have taken part in this piecemeal
destruction of the English language
the Millennials complain about how gen Z
speaks just as Boomers did about
Millennials just as their parents did
about them and all of the complaints
were valid and only becoming more valid
as time goes on we are as a culture
progressively losing the ability to
express ourselves through language and
this is a rather significant problem
given that language is one of the
necessary cornerstones of any
functioning civilization
as I've observed in the past if you
really want to see just how much our
communication skills if not our
communication technology I mean our
technology is getting better our
communication technology is getting
better as our communication skills uh uh
you know are are falling apart but if
you really want to see how it has
deteriorated
all you have to do is go and uh go to
like a civil war Battlefield Museum
somewhere and read some of the letters
that average young men often with little
to no formal education
wrote home to their families to describe
their experiences
the National Park Service keeps an
online database actually I don't need to
go to a museum
and they have so a database of some
letters that were sent from Antietam
and before and after the the Battle of
Antietam so I'll read just the first
this is the first one if you go to this
website the first one that pops up on
the page is this it's from an infantry
private and this is what he writes
he writes on the 8th we struck up the
refrain of Maryland by Maryland and
camped in an apple orchard we went
hungry for six days not a morsel of
bread or meat had gone in our stomachs
and our menu consisted of apple and corn
we toasted we burned we stewed we boiled
we roasted these two together and singly
until there was not a man whose form had
not caved in you know had not a bad
attack of diarrhea our under clothes
were foul and hanging in strips our
socks worn out and half of the men were
barefooted many were lame and were sent
to the rear others of Sterner stuff
hobbled along and managed to keep up
while gangs from every company went off
in the surrounding country looking for
food many became ill from exposure and
starvation were left on the road the
ambulances were full and the whole route
was marked with a sick lame limping lot
that straggled to the farmhouses that
lie in the way and who in all cases
suckered and cared for them
okay so this is a normal guy not even
intending to write something that would
become a matter of the historical record
simply describing his experiences and he
does so in a way that is so elegant and
descriptive
that even if you didn't have any context
you would immediately know that it could
not have been written in this century
now imagine the girl from the podcast
trying to convey the same experience so
like we hadn't uh eaten and like so like
it was it was kind of like uh I don't
know how to say it I I guess like we
were hungry and honestly like it was
kind of gross and like literally we
didn't even have shoes
I probably already made the point but
there's one more letter written by a
private JD Hicks of the Pennsylvania
volunteers
um and he's trying to describe the
horror of finding a boy dead on the
battlefield
this is how he puts it
under the dark shade of a towering Oak
near the dunker Church lay the lifeless
form of a drummer boy apparently not
more than 17 years of age flax and hair
and eyes of blue and form of delicate
mold as I approached him I stooped down
and as I did so I perceived a bloody
Mark upon his forehead it showed where
the leaden messenger of death had
produced the wound that caused his death
his lips were compressed his eyes half
open a bright smile played upon his
countenance by his side lay his tenor
drum never to be tapped again
so this is an utterly haunting poignant
downright poetic account
dashed off in a letter from some young
guy
who couldn't have been much older than
the drummer boy in fact this the this
guy was 18 years old when he wrote that
this is how people used to communicate
okay and so and you could also find
plenty of Civil War letters that where
the spelling is horrendous and the uh
Punctuation is non-existent because
oftentimes again these these were uh
young men and boys that did have formal
schooling but even in those cases
still the language is there's a there's
a wide vocabulary that's evident and the
language is often very evocative and
Vivid and descriptive in a way that
people just aren't capable of anymore
that's how people used to communicate
vividly descriptively with words that
sufficiently captured the ideas they
wanted to convey and the experiences
that they wish to recount
we are a bunch of mumbling inarticulate
cows by comparison
why well for many reasons people don't
read books anymore and so they aren't
exposed to a wide vocabulary they spend
most of their time over stimulated by
screens and videos they communicate
mainly in Internet shorthand relying
heavily on little pictures emojis to
convey tone and emotion because they
don't know how to do it through actual
language when I complain about emojis
people always think that I'm joking and
it's the silly thing to complain about
but this is actually is damaging our
ability to communicate people don't you
hear people say well I got to use an
emoji because otherwise no one knows my
tone they don't know if I'm happy if
I've you know they don't know the tone
of that I'm that I'm using when I
where you're supposed to be able to
communicate that with language you're
supposed to be able to if you're writing
a message to someone use words that
convey whether you're happy or angry or
sad or whatever the fact that you need
the Emoji to do that shows a a troubling
limitation on our language abilities
and on top of all that and partially
because of it IQ scores have been
declining for years
that's how we got here which on the plus
side also gives us a road map for
getting out of the situation
and how you get out of it is do the
reverse basically do the reversal that
of all that put down the screen pick up
a book
use words to communicate
real complete words and sentences
we'll probably never write as well as a
19th century Farm Boy on a Civil War
battlefield okay most of us will never
write that well
but we can improve
I hope we can at least
even that girl in the podcast even she
can improve
but for now because I have to cancel
someone at the end of this that is the
requirement of the segment then I must
say that she is sadly today Cancer
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]